the first part that we try to look at is
that how can we make it as frictionless
as possible by doing Integrations into
existing systems or giving them
something that they are already familiar
with right so that there's no
significant learning power here the
other big Advantage with uh with
generative and and with the coming of
chat GPT is that things have become
conversational right so which is always
a easy because that dramatically cuts
down the learning card right so if you
can give an interface where someone can
just have a conversation saying this is
the problem that I facing this is how it
need a solution and the system
automatically gives the response it
delivers a natural way of of connecting
with with the
[Music]
professional Ruben fuken welcome to 20
minute leaders thank you so much for
spending this time with me how are you I
doing great thank you Michael how are
you I am doing excellent and I'm I'm
excited to dive in with you all about
Limitless learning and knowledge all
about good just your own your own
Journey um the world of Creator economy
content generative AI when it comes to
team learning and research and and
everything in between so uh we we'll
we'll dive straight in because we just
have 20 short minutes H and so Ruben
walk me through a little bit on your
journey and all the way leading up to to
good chest yeah first uh Michael thanks
for having me uh on your show uh I mean
it's great to be here uh so my journey I
have been uh on the T of the AI machine
learning for SL 3 class years uh so I
graduated as a computer engineer and got
the opportunity to work at yada and uh
had the amazing opportunity to work
directly with the co-founder J5
uh in doing what we used to call back
then data uh research which later got
known more popularly as the
aign uh and the whole idea is uh how do
you process the huge amount of data that
uh G generates from all the properties
back then to understand how uh user
Journey moves from one product to
another right so to learn a lot and uh
like to see is brought also Bing by the
C bad and started my
first a vertical search called Vixie and
where the idea was that we uh we learn
from user Searchers across different BS
whether they're looking for a job or
they're looking for application TR so
that we can recomend ROV information to
them right when so that the searches are
very specific to uh what a particular
user may be interest us so we create
their profile so that is where we are
like using AI anding to solve some real
problems starting with recommendation
back then uh so this uh company was
acquired by the Nur of South
Africa and then uh I I've talked to my
second startup which was a Enterprise a
called the dark and there we were sold
with the problem of machine right so as
uh company so this was like ear
2012 where most of the large
manufacturers right they were starting
to deploy sense across their machine now
they were struggling to figure out how
would they use the machine data to make
decision right so that is is where the
RPM came in and said that let us provide
a natural language interface by which
you can actually have a conversation
with machines right identify how the
machines functioning are there any no
that are coming up right and based on
that you can actually identify if there
is a maintenance that is required in the
right and these are like gaster bines
Des are uh assembly line machines
robotic arms and things like that so
that also helps the company plan
inventory and and things better so we
got the amazing opportunity to work with
almost like most of the large
manufacturers got to learn a lot how uh
organizations uh perform especially when
new technology gets introduce and uh so
this uh data op was acquired by progress
software
um in 2017 and uh when we completed the
trans uh uh
transition so the common theme across my
entire Journey has been about using
technology to solve some human scale
problems right so things which cannot be
done manually things uh where uh there
are existing pain points that uh that
algorithms or or uh machine can help
solve
better but that also led to the thing is
that when you are actually applying
technology to solve business problem the
data which technology keeps evolving
right and the whole field of AI and
machine learning has gone through a
massive transition in the past uh 20
plus years is that everybody needs to
constantly upscale themselves right so I
mean whether we uh like lik it or not
everybody is now a lifelong learner
right so whatever uh technology skills
get obsolute really really fast right so
the the halflife uh period of uh
technology skill is like 2.5 years right
so which means that I mean people have
to keep learning new things really
really fast right now that creates uh
the challenges is that we are all also
crunch for time when we have to learn so
many new things right in a short amount
of time uh yeah it we cannot do it like
a traditional learning right so we
cannot spend like weeks or months
learning about new technology and then
applying it on the on the job right so
that became kind of uh the basis of uh
goodes of what we did is that how can we
leverage uh Ai and and uh technology to
generate very irated content which is
specific to individual me right of of
what someone is working on what kind of
technologies that they need to use or
they need to learn about and what
problems are they trying to solved with
it right and then a leverage AI to
generate very very delate content for
that individual and give them the
ability to have a
conversation with the AI more more like
a coach right saying that yeah this is
what I'm working on this is where I
strugly guide me in a step by-step
manner so that's uh that's what we do at
good gist that's the the gist of what
you do at good gist that's
the and so tell me a little bit about
the the the pain point from the
customers angle so if you're looking at
Enterprises if you're looking at the way
that employers and and organizations are
looking at
upskilling and education and being on
top of the learning curve as you're
talking about it what is it actually how
do you how do you actually Define that
pain point and how do you then think it
through in a in a from from a product
perspective in terms of what you're
optimizing
for right so we solve for two problems
so we our our uh our focus is primarily
technology companies or software
companies uh where the the rate at which
technology changes and the rate at which
uh teams need to obscure themselves is
probably the highest um in the industry
like I said that Technologies uh Stills
get obsolute and the half life is only
2.5 years so uh there are two problems
that we solve so one is the internal
problem is that how do technology teams
keep themselves up to date with things
which are moving so fast right and this
can cannot be done through the
traditional uh topown approach of
Learning and Development because um if a
generate course content is being
provided right so first is that the time
to prepar course content is months right
and then the the time the cost that it
takes right and the time that it takes
to generate that uh content doesn't
really help the organiz ization because
maybe by the time the content is ready
lot of things are change right the
content becomes Obsolete and the other
challenge with a generic one siiz with
all uh content it's that doesn't really
help people who are on the job and
trying to solve the problem the reason
being is that in the technology world
everybody is working with different
technology sta right they have different
level of proficiency so the same content
will not be useful for everyone in the
same way just to give an example uh
let's say now generative a is huge right
so if you look from an organization
perspective uh engineer who is trying to
apply generative a to build a product
has very different requirements of of
what they want to understand about
generative and application then let's
say someone who is on the infrastructure
side and trying to figure out how
generative a fits into their scheme of
things right because it becomes more
like how do you deploy and manage uh a
generative a model right or if you look
from a business user perspective so
their requirement is very different it's
like how can generative help them grow
their business so you cannot have a
one-size fitall
Content so that's the first pinpoint
that we solve because generative
the general content is more like
information right it doesn't really
translate into knowledge that can be
directly apply so that's the problem
that we solve is that when a individual
comes onto the platform and say that
this is what I want to learn about this
is why I want to learn about right and
this is how I get to apply that learning
our platform will generate very concise
to I mean uh structured content which is
just relevant for that individual right
or or just relevant for a team so this
helps them move with their uh job much
faster it helps them to learn something
why they are working on a problem and
and get done so this this gives a
dramatic uh Improvement to the
productivity of of employ okay the
Second Use is that we solve for is a lot
of software Company sell by a
Partners so they have to constantly keep
uh upskilling their partner to be able
to either sell their software or
implement it for customer right now this
creates a huge challenge because again
as things move fast and and that
training has to be very tender made to
the use skes that the partner is working
on so again uh giving that example say
uh generative AI company and who was
trying to sell that through partners for
multiple domains like finance and
Healthcare right now a partner was
trying to implement that for the
healthare domain have to take care of
the regulations have to take care of how
healthare system works and and all of
those right when they're trying to
implement the solution there whats is
someone trying to do for the financial
world will have very very different
requirements so the partner creating the
partner onboarding and the partner
enablement also become very very
specific in terms of how the knowledge
is delivered right now this cannot be
done manually at
scale right that's the second paino that
we solve is that we help companies
enable Partners in an autonomous way
right where the AI will generate very
specific content for the partner in
terms of um training them how to apply
the software for a particular customer
right so a this makes the partner more
effective it makes the partner deliver
proper solution to the customer so the
customers are happy so the company gets
to generate more revenue and the company
doesn't need to invest in a large
partner support team because the partner
is almost self-sufficient right and and
they need to the support team needs to
come in when the partner is not able to
resolve the problem through
the so those are the two use cases
that and and what have you learned about
the I guess the the consumer behavior in
terms of engaging with with this type of
work so as you're looking at all the way
Downstream to the actual person who's
gaining the knowledge and going through
the experience from a product
perspective I think a big a big
interesting question is how do how do we
how do we create these products that
leverage generative AI um in a way that
that are not just engaging but are
actually useful um to on on the actual
customer experience so those that are
gaining the skills so what what if you
what are some interesting insights that
you've had there about the user
experience from your
product yeah so I think the most
important thing is to start with the
problem that that end user has and how
they actually we solve or try to solve
that problem in their current workflow
right because the entire user experience
has to be tailor made or or has to fit
into that workflow right so we cannot
ask the user I mean for example if a lot
of work is being done on the on the web
on on the desktop station right you
cannot ask the give a mobile app to the
users and say that hey do it on on your
phone right it's not going to work so a
lot of that user experience is
determined by how the individuals work
today right so uh that's the first part
that we try to look at is that how can
we make it as frictionless as possible
by doing Integrations into existing
systems or giving them something that
they're already familiar with right so
that there's no significant learning
power here the other big Advantage with
uh with generative and and with the
coming of chat GPT is that things have
become conversational right so which is
always a easy thing because that
dramatically cuts down the learning card
right so if you can give an interface
where someone can just have a
conversation saying that this is the
problem that I facing this is how it
need a solution and the system
automatically gives the response it
delivers a natural way of of connecting
with with the professionals right so so
that's the second piece
of so tell me a little bit about where
you're at today so good just is up and
running the world where where you at in
terms of of customers in terms of your
engagement what when and and and
following that a little bit about the
vision of of where you see this heading
where do you see this Market of all to
and and and what is the big potential
that you see for
goodest yeah so uh we started this
company
um last year towards in the in the last
quarter of the year we did uh Alpha
launch of the product in January right
and and we recently did the beta launch
of the product we been working with uh
almost like 20 plus different uh
companies are trying to understand their
requirements trying to see how and and
this spans across multiple use cases
right these are uh small organizations
large organizations using it for
internal uh training needs or using it
for their partner or customer
requirements right so this is this has
given us a spectrum of uh understanding
of how different organizations work what
are the different
uh use GES when it comes to General
Knowledge Management or learning uh
across uh so uh in in terms of the
vision where we see the industry going
because I think there is a fundamental
shift that is happening in the industry
when it comes to learning and Knowledge
Management from a more topout driven
approach to a more B Mark it's about
empowering individuals because when you
really look at learning right so
learning is very personal every
individual has a different level of
proficiency they have different goals uh
they have different uh objectives work
objectives that they're trying to learn
for and they have different work
schedules where learning has to fit into
right so the topown approach which which
the
traditional um learning industry which
is already a 300 plus billion dollar
industry right
has been catering to was more of a top
down and and of course it was because
it's a human scale uh limitation issue
because you cannot create tail liate
content for individuals right on a
manual we right so you cannot create
like thousand uh different versions of
the courses right manually but that is
where that AI scale AI can deliver that
CH scale right so it actually enables us
to now deliver truly personalized
learning right on on need basis so that
opens up the opportunity in a in a
massive way it's it's very disruptive uh
for the industry and um and we see
ourselves as one of the initial players
in in in that Stace although we are
focusing on specific Niche at that point
but the technology that we have built
enables to cater to pretty much any uh
learning needs right across across
organizations so that is what makes us
more excited that we are able to deliver
very very specific uh learning needs
right so which is to the point fits into
the daily schedule of of uh individuals
and it's more like On Demand right so
you you just have a conversation you get
whatever you need to do to uh get the
work done so the the productivity gug
that we have seen across uh our early
Pilots that we have done right has been
phenomenal because earlier what people
used to do is that they would go through
the traditional online uh courses and
then what that would do is that help
them identify what do what are the
pieces of information that they need to
search for when they're going to apply
it on the job right so someone go to an
online learning and look up say a
generative course they get a very broad
idea now when they have to apply from
the job so they would do a web search
right they would dynamically try to
recall some of those information or see
what fits into the exact requirement
right that takes a lot of time because
uh and the and the industry stat is that
almost like 30% of uh individuals day
goes into just searching for information
right and that's a huge productivity law
and when you see that that knowledge is
also not captured right someone does
that web search gets that information
it's all in their head they solve a
particular problem that day at work
right they have to recall that
information let's say one month down the
line unless they have they have recorded
it they'll have to repeat the whole
process right so these are some not the
big change uh I mean there are pain that
uh businesses have been enduring think
that yeah these are not solvable P but
now with a we are able to solve that
able to deliver the productivity yeah
and which is what makes it exciting
Reuben thank you so much for joining me
this is awesome and best of luck with
goodest and everything that you're doing
I'm excited about where learning is
going in the world and personalized
learning on demand real time up to dat
all of those aspects so thank you again
for taking this time to share with me
and best of luck with a good thank you m
and thanks for me again